Thank you for the long wait um and
patience. Um we are going to start the
special seminar we are hosting
uh Mandela bright
uh from the Michigan State University
and today he's going to talk about
exciting topic which is smarter
particles for smarter plasma patients.
So the stage is here. Thank you very
much and thank you all again for
waiting. Yeah. Um so as just said
presenting on this moment enhanced fatal
cell work which we are using particles
for plasma nations. This work is John's
collaborative efforts
between my advisor and
the also of Michigan State University
Josh of UT
Austin of Georgia Institute. We are
being founded by Los
Alamos Foundation Champ and also
student.
So today um this is the plan for my talk
today. I'm sure we have diverse
audience. So we talk a little bit about
plasma. We talk about modeling and then
particle itself. Then a method that was
developed by Dennis helmet pleasantly we
will try to do something about what we
have done. Then we see how we we
improved it using
school approach a paper that they wrote
in
1994 built upon develop this before we
do that we'll look at some preliminaries
then we look at some
applications and then also talk
about numerical effects and then some
proposal. So as uh most of the members
in this audience will know plasma is an
ionized gas as we heat it from solid
becomes liquid from liquid becomes gas
and as the temperature decreases this
what happens and it's used in basically
it's it's about 99% of the physical
earth physical environment is made up of
glass we use it for medical
stabilization in TV plasma not in the
solution energy. So in our quest of we
get clean energy we that's why we also
studying plasma I'm sure soon we'll be
able to get the answer that we have been
looking for all these years so why
didn't because plasma is important we
need to model we want to model it and
we'll look at this simple analogy
here if we want to model n pars and want
to loop over them that is computing the
colum force we have this information
that we see here. And then if you want
to calculate the electric field that
means we here we doing it for all the
particles. So that means you able to
loop over n minus one particles and that
means that we require n minus one force
per particles and that means that the
total cost will be about
n² and clearly realize that as n
increases is going to be very very
particular. So we want to find ways of
means to be able to compute these things
get accurate answers but also be
efficient. Let's elaborate together. So
let's assume we have n which is 10^ 60
particles. Here we look this is at least
the B
min which is there is about 60 particles
m pressure and then also if we decide
that based on a simple realize that the
column interaction take about 10 - 8
seconds to complete hence the total
interactions which we just looked at the
n minus one end up having 5 * 10^
10^ 31
one in total interactions and using the
10^ you realize that approximately it
will take us 1.6 six times 10 is the
past 16 years to do that computing if
you want to do that
and using the machine the as November
the most powerful machine which is C
plus when we do this calculations the
performance is 1.742 Exact and if we
assume 100 FLs per interaction that
means we end up having about
910,000 to do the same calculations So
even though the total time here is a lot
we end up having
9 110 almost a billion years to be able
to a million years to be able to compute
this. So realize that hence we need
faster methods like particle itself to
do plasma
simulations and one of the key equations
that is able to govern plasma
simulations well it's a blasop and then
in terms of blasop we have these three
uh basically equations the f is just
talking about the distribution function
which is made up of the position and
then the momentum and then the fi is the
potent basically the potential. Then
this is the blasto equation. This
particular one the middle one is
the is the blasov equation bl equation
and then this is the known pass
equation. So together they become the
pass equation. Now here the fields are
self consistently determined by f. So
everything here is self consistent.
Okay, we don't have a prescribial here.
Now, what then is a particle itself?
What we are trying to make better, it's
basically a numerical technique that
combines the particle base method and
the three base methods into together to
get this. I'll use this picture to
elaborate together. So, basically
earlier when we saw the n particles, we
are going to have them to cluster
together to form something like the
super particles or macroparticles. So
the microparticles will represent group
of real particles which automatically
will reduce the conditional loop. So
this what we have as equation
one as equation one. So this the idea
here is this you have these particles
then you put them on the grid. So these
particles then that's what we have as
our cake. So if we have about a million
particles here, we able to reduce the
number of particles to a little less
than the median or sometimes a
significant significantly lower that's
what we able to see as the one as P. So
this is the idea of P. So from here
we're able to solve we'll look at the
algorithm shortly for you to see how. So
this is the algorithm for P. What you do
is that you initialize the particles
here. The standard one we use was the
momentum and then the position. You
deposit the charge on the mesh. That's
that's what we just saw in the previous
picture. Then we solve the electric
field on the mesh. Then we interpolate
the the electric field onto the
particles. Then we announce the
particles using the information that we
got and the cycle
keeps. So when we use PE want to see why
P is better than doing it as a direct
method as we just saw when we assume 10^
9 realize that the complexity will
reduce to just 10 to the^ 16 operations
and if the flops is 10^ 18 running on
the same L cap you realize
that something that was close to a
million will now just be a subsecond
computation very fast. So you realize
that P at the end is able to help us
model plasma better at least without a
lot of additional cost. But clearly we
know that P will always have problems.
Any model will have problems as my
advisor keep saying all models are not
perfect. Some some are better than the
others. So we want to see how we could
improve this model. And these are the
main problems that we saw with
P physical and numerical. So uh the
annoyance used in finite particle
sampling the energy is not really
conserved and also it struggles to
resolve the fine uh the fine scale
velocity structures. Computationally
it's expensive in high
dimensions. It also prepass more time
steps to able to get stability. And then
in terms of when you're trying to
paralyze them, there's a problem with
load imbalance. In terms of the
algorithm itself, there's a there's a
problem with complex charts in position
and
interpolation. Then it's also very
difficult to handle
collisions and that and then also
there's also a problem when you are
dealing with multiple conditions. Now
you realize that they are some of them
are colorful. Our method basically has
been the green ones are things that our
method has been able to solve. So we
have been able to solve the green ones
better the green ones and then the
yellow ones at least we have an idea
that it's working and then the um the
black ones are basically what we we have
not really come to terms with or we have
not be able to see any kind of
improvement you know as we keep
researching and then making enhancing
our method maybe we'll be able to solve
the other better the other black so
basically our has reduced noise our
preserves
uh energy. Our our able to resolve the
finite uh fine scale velocity structures
better than P and then also in terms of
the complex deposition ours is able to
look at it better or handle it better.
In terms of
computational ours is not as expensive
as P and then ours is easily to paralyze
as compared to
P. So what is SW particle? We are not
the first to think about SW particles
but Dennis Hart came up with his and the
reference that you can see down there
that is DH fragmentation emerging and
internal dynamics for P simulations with
finite side particles if you look at it
so all he did was if you have the
standard P he's able and then this is
the normal particles the real particles
and then these are our one super
particles what we
This what we know we just
described. What he did was he says you
could be able to rather have a macrople
for the real particles have a microp
particles with this particular
representation which he calls the
CP particle or in a way a span particle.
So what happens is if you have the P
structure which is the Q and P, he is
able to decompose it into one have a
share S. The share S link the the
momentum and then the position together.
He has a V pin that is the momentum
width is able to track that one and then
also a particle weight which is a W kn
and then a special way as well and this
is able to capture the fluid and the
kinetic properties better at least what
when he does that this is what he's able
to do and then also he's able to track
the internal dynamics using this
particular equation the paper is a very
um I encourage
audience to be able to look at it. But
when he did this, so he did this. But
the key thing here is that he's using it
only for
gians. That's that's what it also
doesn't solve the Hamiltonian problems.
It doesn't it's not energy conserving
and this is one of the what we realize
that okay can we make this thing better
and that's where we so let's look at the
limitations of the speaking method. one
it's rigid as I said earlier it only
supports goship particles it's not it
ignores Hamilton completely it's
hamilton is not preserved and then
anytime you want to handle anything in
it you need to manually adapt it so it's
kind of difficult and then also in terms
of diagnostics you always use you need
to use stringers and um one key problem
that it cannot go beyond the second
order limit we talk about it later. So
this is what parents tried doing in 2003
but I realized that these are some of
the limitations that they have. So again
we are not the first particle someone or
a couple of people have tried doing that
already. So what we did was using an
approach by Google but to able to
understand it I'll look at a little
preliminaries because it's based on
algebra most of the stuff we are working
with is based on algebra. So some a
little preliminaries so first of all
look at the bracket structure. So
basically a bracket that you see here on
a smooth manifold M is basically a bine
map that maps this into that which is
the final smooth function X Y C
satisfying these four properties one
anti-ymmetry uh it needs to uh the
bracket should satisfy anti-ymmetry it
should be linear that is if you have C1
C2 it should satisfy situation it should
also follow what we call the left place
rule more or less is basically something
like an associity and then also one
important key thing is it needs to
follow the job identity. So when you
have any any this map with this four
properties then we are calling it as a
person. Now one key thing is that the
blasop system itself has something to do
with the so we want to build from there.
We'll start by looking at structure. So
we say that a system is if when you find
a derivative
of when you find the derivative of f
with that with a bracket with this. If
this thing holds then the system is for
all f in this particular where h also
belongs to that. So when this thing
holds then the system is again realize
that in the method it didn't satisfy the
opportunity. We want to have a system
that will present the opportunity. So
that's why we are looking at it
carefully. So if we let our n this time
be gi
star more or less wow I'll explain it
to if you let n be that and then we
define the person bracket as what we are
saying here this person
bracket then the hamiltonian functional
have this and using the uh the equation
we
have issues
with. So this so basically the person
system this what it follows this is the
face this person bracket this functional
with it equation.
So with these two foundation we are
ready to see whether the person how it
deals with legebra. Now a le algebra G
is a vector space over maybe R or
complex numbers which is equipped with
the le brackets. This here you realize
that all the um all the stuff that has
to do with
the P brackets bracket structure it's
almost apart from the lips. So realize
that it's bilinear it's anti-ymmetry it
follows the identity. So realize
that anytime you have a le algebra this
properties must be what satisfied
examples are matrices which is under
commutator vector fields under
derivatives and etc. So these are what
make us rise. Now now we have the tools
to be able to see why the le the quason
is a leas system. Why is it a leas
system? If we have g the le algebra of
smooth functions on the face and we have
the with equipped with this particular
bracket then the uh aims that we just
saw or the box that we saw we just saw
the it being the anti- symmetry the
jacobian identity is satisfy and the G
star I talked about that means that it
dual space G star will be equipped or it
evol it evolves under this particular
bracket and this is what we get to
realize that then the le structure
underline the
blasphe so the whole idea is mostly you
always want to find a closure a hamilton
moment closure for some of these system
but we can't it
content So why a closure is hamiltonian
provided these three things told one a
person bracket exist the hamiltonian is
defined and the dynamics will be what we
saw the definition for what for the
habit. So the whole idea is if you have
this sequence moment sequence we want to
find out as K approaches infinity will
we be able to recover the person bracket
that's the goal here this is what her
method couldn't achieve but this what we
want to see whether we can
so to do that anytime we
have a algebra we want to see whether we
can approximate it and that's what we
have this question in. He says, "Is it
possible to construct a algebra that
approximates G whose dwell captures a
finite number of fluid movements?" And
the answer is yes. Yes. True algebraic
reductions. So these are the there are
two main methods to able to approximate
the algebra either quotient algebra or
sub algebra. But in this case with the
main idea here is that the quotient
algebra fails and then the sub algebra
also fails. But what Google the geniums
that they did was you were able to find
a way to merge the parts of both the
quotient algebra and then the sub
algebra together. So that's looking at
in the next slide. So what is the
quotient algebra? Basically if we have
we have a le algebra ideal a subspace i
is an ideal if the bracket in i for all
a in i and x in g basically that's what
the algebra ideal is and then the
quotient algebra is form we form when
you have the g and then this particular
i then we are having the quotient
algebra so just to make life easier for
everyone an example is that if let all g
be all polomial So pol in X. So that is
1 X X etc. And we we decide to take I to
be the polomial division of X. So
basically then our G/ R will only be
made up of one and X. Basically every
term above X will be cut off. So this
will only retain constant and linear
terms. And this is where it's a bit
problematic. And why is it so? So let's
take an
example. If you take a function where we
have QP in the constant terms and then
take the PB plus the curve part like a
normal polinomial and it will retain
only Q and P then the space is not
closed on the brackets. Why? You realize
that this will hold this will hold. But
any time that has to do with any q^² qv
or more will keep appearing the false
inclusion of yet higher tense which we
don't want the the algebra does not
hence will truncate and this is the
reason why co of algebra often fails to
support consistent moment quotient so
this is why quotient algebra doesn't
really work then I talk about sub
algebra so a sub algebra
Let's look at the definition of it. A
subspace H subset of G is a subra if
when you take H1 and H2 in H and we take
a bracket of it for all what H1 and H2
it's still in H. A typical example is a
3x3 matrices the upper triangular 3x3
matrices. So when you take this and then
you realize that all the terms that's
why earier I told you about the matrices
they are what the algebra. So here some
of this may close under the bracket
range. Again it's problematic here. Why?
Let's take uh the function here where we
have
C C uh with C1 and up etc. And then uh
we try pairing the W here with the with
this. Then the bracket produces terms of
order
P. Even though we only want this
sequence, the bracket will produce P
raised to the power and beyond which
will automatically break the closure. So
the space of polinomial functions of
degree are not basically subordinates.
So this is the reason why you can't just
go ahead and approximate this system
just by sub algebra or by just algebra.
So what did Sco what did they do? They
take the G and then split it into B and
then S. Well, both B and S are sub
algebra. But here is the trick. They
find an ideal in what? In S. But this
ideal is in S. But do not need to be an
idolic. So this this is how powerful
this what their main paper is all about.
How this how they were able to cure this
problem of sub algebra and then push to
algebra by a what we call what they call
hybridization. They try to hybridize the
two methods. So how is it done? So let B
be a label that integrates B the the
data that you see here. So this is our
if you
see so if you have this what happens is
you're able to
map we're able to map this using this
map here to this so this
again okay so as I said here we have B
and then
The whole idea again is the B you have
the G and then the B and then the S. The
B will be more or less controlling the
motion and then S will be controlling
the shape. This the whole idea. So the S
and in terms of the shape that means the
moment now they came up this when you
look at the paper I think I have a
reference here. Yes. So when you look at
this be able to decompose this thing
using this particular map and then also
decompose this particular map and then
end up getting the dual that's the whole
idea on this paper and it's it's very
very powerful. The paper is a big test.
You need to have a little like a bit
knowledge about classical mechanics and
then theory. But it's it's it's a very
quick. So to make life easier, this is
the whole
idea. You apply a subtropical reduction
using B. Then you apply a quotient
reduction using the ideal I in S. Then
when you do that you able to combine
both reduction via a direct sound
structure which embed the result in the
original space and also this time to
preserve the person bracket structure
and hence the
hab. So this is the reference to the
paper this 1994 paper it's a very good
idea. So again let's see why it work
this time around. So if you have the D
algebra
B the sub algebra encoding the
symmetries and then S the complimentary
sub algebra which has to be the linear
AP functions then the I in the S here is
the idea imposing the closure
conditions. So if you want to find the
moment closure basically the uh the
zerooth moment will have the density and
then the first moment which will be the
s will have the what momentum and this
um hybrid reduction that is the sub
algebra plus the quotient of algebra
will end up supporting the hamiltonian
crucial. So to get this whole thing done
the most important thing here is what is
the map and this is what we call the
spark particles. The idea is you start
with two particles a particle with only
two information Q and P but you end up
having this delta functions here using
the method that we have talked
about. If we look at it in our paper
currently we are working on publishing
it soon. So I'm I'm hoping at least I'll
give it to
Dr. So when you do that you end up
having this as you can see here the
interpretation here it combines particle
data and the truncated moment to
represent the f within the space and
that's why we call it a spam. What
happens basically you start with only
two informations Q and P but you then
have more information attached to it. So
normally you started with only two
information and you end up having six
informations and that's why we are
calling this Python because the
information that has you have more
information to deal with the system. So
automatically in getting this map it
comes with it or it more there's an
induced person bracket that comes with
it and when you look at it carefully you
realize that the first aspect of the
person bracket before the sum has to do
with the
standard bracket for the normal person
equation and then the additional aspect
has to do with the what the s the moment
aspect of it. So this bracket is induced
as I said earlier by the quason map and
that supports
momentian system. You could also look
at one of the papers from one of our
collaborator JW Bry. He also handled
this in terms of varable moment fluid
closures. Okay. So with what we we have
seen the theory behind all that we have
done we want to see how we will be able
to um bring it into a numerical result.
So I'll try to make it a bit uh easy for
people to follow. So basically we we
start with the standard P particle. This
is
standard. Now these particles now exist.
Let's assume we have about 100. Then we
decide to cluster these particles. So
when we cluster these particles we by
finding the mean here we use the K beans
algorithm as our start. So end up having
this uh new uh more or less the weights
new kills and new PS and these are the
averages. Then we then find the
deviations of this of of um the
deviations the first order deviations
using approximation. So that's what we
did here. So then each parallel will end
up becoming spans. So basically that's
what we have
here the last bit of it. So we started
with only QP now we have Q P Q star P
star and then S star. To the best of our
knowledge we are the first to be able to
handle this to able to get a particular
kind of result that we are showing you
today.
So basically our standard P now becomes
this new P. So is now this particular
one. The new F becomes this. This is
what we are calling the
SP here. Then it comes with it own
person brackets and that's what we see
and when you have these two then we are
basically ready to solve the system. We
have what we call the reduce Hamiltonian
or the collective Hamiltonian which is a
pull back because the original
Hamiltonian will not work. The original
one break and then based on new
variables that we have you end up having
this particular variables the new
variables instead of Q and P now we now
have these six variables using simpletic
lead for we solve this problem.
So we have seen all the method we have
seen how we think it will work. I want
to see whether it will work in real
life. So let's start with a prescribed
potential a very simple to exam. So this
is original here we having our standard
particle original particles. So they are
six up here six down here. Then we
cluster them that is we pair them pair
them here. And then we also have super
particles
here. So this I I can't say for sure
that these two are what is here.
Yes. That's me.
Awesome. Okay. So, let me
rewind. So, let's
see. Okay. So, we are going to solve the
toy example to make sure what we have
done works. To start we want to see how
we can compare it with the standard
particle and in standard particle that
means L here this L when L should be
either zero or one. So that's what we
have here that SK is zero E is one and
then we using the potential of sign Q.
So what we do here is as I explained in
the as I said I'm starting a we begin
with
12 par. So that's what we have here. Six
up there, six down there. Then we use K
means cluster to bring them together.
And I I'll said earlier that I can't say
for sure that it's these two particles
that come here that bite for this. The
reason is that the h it needs to account
for both the position and then the
momentum to able to know which one is
too close to bring them together. But
likelihood it's possible that it's these
two that is uh being uh what that is
coming to this side and then these two
will come to this and then these two
come to that at least let's see that one
and then the same applies to the one in
red. So here the original 12 particles
have been reduced to just six particles.
We want to see will it
matter and the answer we now use
the we now get a new Hamiltonian that is
the prescribed potential we get a new
Hamiltonian here that's the glass of
Hamiltonian this the distribution
function we want it to compare to the
standard part and then this the
collective Hamiltonian this how it
evolve and then using this particular
person brackets you end up I think this
systems of equation. So this where our
method more or less is a bit of a
disadvantage because in the standard
particles you only solve for Q and then
P. But in our method you are solving for
Q P the big side Q star and then the P
star and the small star the canical
miracles. But if you look at the
equations carefully, you realize that
the the S basically are not really
coupled or they are not coupled with the
with the other four variables. The the
big S is just this and then the small
star S star is just a constant. So this
one so I'll talk about it later. I just
wanted you to notice. So in a nutshell
basically in as much as we are solving
six we might basically be solving only
four variables here. So for this after
time t= to 15 this how the movement goes
and then in our in s pick this what we
now
see once you see so this how the
variable the new variables works. So
this is just for only one remember they
were 12 reduced to six. So we just pick
the zero one and then this how it
evolves over time. The Q this how it's
evolving. The P this how it's evolving.
The S keeps evolving this way. And then
the size bar it's kind of small but this
how it evolves. It looks like it's
bounded. The P star also very small and
it's descending. And then as we uh we
know the size is what is a constant
originally it was one and then since
it's now two based on the formula that
we saw earlier that's why you see 2.0
Now not all the all the uh the 12 will
not act the same way. All sorry all the
six will not act the same way. We are
just I'm just using this as an example
for you to see that the evolve evolves
all of them evolves different.
Yes. So now I want to see whether our
system is working. So we want to find
the Hamiltonian evolution. So when you
look at the evolution you realize that
our SW
pick that is the the blue one and then
the standard P that is the orange one
and when look at the the table that you
see here in a nutshell the SW p has 36
variables and then the standard P
because it's 6 * 6 make it is 36 and the
standard P has 24 variables that is 2 *
12 that's 24 and then in terms of drift
S S S S S S S S S S S S S S S S S S S S
S W P P P P P P P P P P P P P P P P P P
P P out perform standard P. The root in
RMS also S SP is better than standard P
and in terms of the noise as well SP is
better than standard P. So we realize
that our method a to example that we
have is working again you have the group
of particles you reduce them or cluster
them and then get the information to
make this matter then we use that to
what evolve and then find the systems of
equation in terms of this new set of
variables and then that's what we are
seeing the hamiltonian being preserved
here there's a bit of deviations because
definitely because we are clustering
them the it will not be lying exactly on
the on the they will not be lying
exactly on each
other. Okay. So now that it want to now
apply it to a normal problem a standard
problem a 1 v1 d starting page. So this
is uh
blasation again we are still using sk=
to z. So this is what we have and this
time around we used finite element
method to be able to solve this problem.
Why? Because the f method automatically
comes with its own shape functions which
will be basically in be in sync with our
method. It's able to handle data
functions naturally and then the
variational problem itself or
formulation normally supports periodic
publications and that's the reason why
we stick to firm uh we are trying to see
in our next we try to apply to form we
also try to use other methods maybe
final volume etc to solve it but for now
in our first problem this what we trying
to do so we have the problem and we got
the weight formulation. We got the the
matrices the the the stiffness matrix
and then
the vector the vector that is using the
the density char density we able to get
this side. Now one key thing is you
realize now we are dealing with a lot of
equations. So one of you need to keep
track of the derivatives in terms of k1
then this one of them. I just wanted you
to see how uh it evolves because in the
collective the structure I didn't
present the structure this so you have
your f and when you find the derivative
of it you need to keep track of it so it
looks like what we are having here. So
now that we
have the system our k our f we know the
collective here and everything we go
ahead and find our discrete this what we
have as our
discrete. Now realize that it comes with
the some of the canonical variables as
possible. Then using
theian and also the partial brackets
that we saw earlier we end up having
this evolution equations. And again if
you look at it carefully you realize
that this side the two side mimic the
toy example that we saw it's still
constant and then these values are
basically what you saw earlier and then
this four also are the same 1 / n and
then so by just using your eye to check
realize that the prescribed potential
has some kind of similarities with the
selfconsistent one. Now uh only Q PK Q
style P PK style evolves the rest are
not uh cy is a constant and big is
auxilian. So now that we have our setup
use the KB algorithm get our B star and
everything we now apply to streaming
stability to see how it performs. So
basically in terms of two stability is a
well
known kinetic simulations where you have
two counter beams coming a blue and then
a red and then with time you want to see
the instability fall. So we compare our
standard pick with our SW with the SW
pick over time. So when you look at it
um originally they started with being
deviated just like the two examples all
the red were up all the up at time t= to
25 you end up seeing this at time t got
to 50 you end up seeing that and at time
t= to 75 you end up seeing this. So
realize that in as much as automatic we
we know that it will not lie they will
not lie on each other because here we
are compressing them but realize that
the instability is forming the face
looks like it's
matching okay now if it's working let's
see the growth rates of of them realize
that both the P and then the SP both of
them follows the theoretical value so
end up so what are we seeing realize
that and this particles here the
standard P is using 100 100,000
particles and the SW p is using just
20,000 particles so we able to use
lesser particles to be able to comput to
get the same result that would have used
100 100,000 particles to
get okay and then we are getting the
growth which the growth rates also
similar we didn't stop there okay if
it's working for two stream only work
for Land so we London dump as well where
a wave a wave is moving and then as
energy is more or
less the initial conditionally what you
can see here. So we did that again and
this is this is the result the standard
pick is using 100,000 particles and then
the SW pick is using only 20,000
particles. So when you look at this
realize that it follows the same thing.
Then in terms of the decay rate it
follows the blue one is for P and then
the green one is for SW big. Here we are
we try to bombard add so many particles.
So we are comparing this result
with a continuum code. So that's what we
did here. We compare the result with the
continuum code. We are using the
continuum as
the the truth truth uh the truth our
ground truth or the truth
solution. So when we compare everything
I want to look at the error scale. So
here we want to see how that 100,000
particles 18,000 particles how do they
perform. So when you look at a standard
P using just with 1% relative error
which is the red one here realize that
to get that you need with 20,000
particles you're able to get
1% but you need about 80,000 particles
to do the same thing for SW sorry for
standard P. So in terms of uh our error
you will see clearly which means that
our method is reducing the noise as the
noise is being reduced more or less in
terms of how the Monte Carlo sampling is
done our method is what outperforming it
again when you look at plot the log on a
log scale you realize that the S sw is
outperforming the standard pick um and
um the deviations as you can see because
it's the same what we saw earlier is
what we are putting it on a log scale
the same result this is for two streams
we got a similar results for uh land as
well now one key thing we didn't look at
earlier before but in at the end of our
work we realized that there's another
advantage and that's what I keep saying
that so let me explain it here
so achieve 1% error with just 50,000
particles. The standard P needs about
100,000 particles to get to the same
thing. What has happened is that we have
been able to reduce the particles by
five
times in terms of particle count.
Then when look at the table and when you
are using just using 88
by standard P for 100,000 you have two
variables. The degrees of freedom
basically is 200,000. So the memory here
you need 1.53 to do the same thing 1.53.
Now when you use S
sw we have six variables. We are using
the normal one because we saw six
variables we using it. So and we having
20,000 variables. So we end up having
120,000 variable which is about 0.92. So
basically we have been able to our
method is saving memory as compared to
the standard even if we use our full S.
Now if we decide to ignore the the size
star when we ignore that one because we
know it's a constant then we have what
we call optimized SP and that means we
save about 50% of what space and then
when we ignore both the S and then the S
key where we are calling the minimal P
you end up saving
about 60 to 60% of what of memory
So basically this one we didn't look at
it this earlier but we realiz that this
is a very important advantage that we we
are having as uh the work progressed. So
tracking only variables will reduce the
memory storage by 60% compared to what
to the standard and that's one advantage
that we saw. So basically this is what
we have realized one in this method
hamilton structure is preserved it's
less noisy
computationally be able to save memory
as compared to standard p and then all
in terms of the algorithm itself is ter
of the position and then interpolation
our method is what is also way better
than the standard method in terms of
what we want to do next our proposed or
what we want continue from here one
instead of we just ignoring the moment
aspect we now want to add the moment
aspect to it because in as the first one
is the zero moment we want to increase
it to what to that's one thing that we
want to do want and then the goal here
is to move into GPU and then use and
cabana to go to proper advanc computing
to get these things done and then also
we use K means algorithm here once to
try other kind of clustering algorithm
that will make the method a bit faster
but we we know that as easy we are
getting 20,000 five times reduction we
might even do better than that yes so
basically this is what uh we have we're
able to build a structure preserving
model via the scoo reduction that's what
we are calling the s that we pick we
represented the particles using delta
functions and their derivatives
And then we able to extend the P with
higher order moment and then geometric
structures. Our key result is that we
recovered P as a special case. We're
able to capture the shape variables by
this moment and then we were able to
reduce the face state noise. There is
low memory usage and then in terms of
the limit is what is also concerned that
is it
energy. Thank you very much.
Thank you. Thank you so
much. Let's have a Q&A
session. That's
great. Well, um I see
that your
smart was it
one extended to 2D or maybe 3D. So when
the structure for 2D is the same
thing it's going to be smart get more
variables automatically if it's 2D 3D
the
variables sorry the standard P also
increase because each P will have if
it's two P1 P2 and it will increase the
same applies to ours but in terms of the
advantage in our results we are still
doing better as compared to still saving
space and
Do do you expect that saving will
increase as you go higher dimensional?
Yes.
All right. We have a question from
um
Jun. He
asked, "Thank you, Mandela. It's a great
talk for particle and cell simulation.
Sometimes you have to split and merge
those macrooles during the splitting and
merging process. Does this scheme also
satisfy the conservation of energy
momentum charges and mass? Yes, it does
because in what way the work that we are
building what happens there's a
pullback. So as they split there's a way
that the ideal in the air is able to end
up having that pull back and that will
that will help us to make sure the habit
is conserved and hence the energy is
also conserved. But the whole idea here
is that we wanted to energy concept. So
the splitting and diverging the the kind
of the the hybridization that we are
working to con
that's thank you. Uh is there any other
questions? Yes.
Uh you uh unmute and then ask. Okay. Hi
I was wondering uh if you had I wrote it
down but uh I was wondering if you had
any nonlinear examples to show. It's all
very well and good to show two extremely
elementary linear problems and claim
with great chest pumping that one is
conserving energy but energy
conservation or structure conservation
is challenged with nonlinear problems
only. So do you have any examples of two
stream with finite temperature low
enough and close enough beams where you
have chaotic evolution and just exactly
how much of that do you preserve with
your low order moment schemes?
Yes. So that's uh the next work that we
are working on. So this one is our first
paper that we realize that it's working
and the one the the nonlinear examples
even for
nonlinear London dumping etc. We have
worked on it. We realize that results
it's how do you call it is showing good
results over there as well. So I'm sure
in our subsequent paper we able to get
that one show but the structure is the
structure is preserving
it's working for that one. So based on
the result that we have I asked about
the two stream nonlinear line out amping
is a steady state solution. So again
it's trivial. The question is, have you
looked at non-trivial problems such as
uh two stream instability uh run long
enough that it'll become highly
nonlinear way way past the linear growth
rate phase?
Okay. No, I've not we have not done
that. It's a good question. Then I'll
note it and then maybe
Thank you. Okay. Sounds good. Uh next
question is by Jan. Jan, would you
unmute yourself and ask a question
directly?
Oh yeah. Hi. Um um you in the talk you
were referring to particle in cell like
standard particle in cell. Um but only
uh you considered uh direct delta
functions
uh for them. But modern particle and
cell methods typically have uh be
splines or uh shape functions
uh of particles. So it's not really just
a simple particle but some uh smooth
function uh to reduce that numerical
heating and uh uh also uh reduce that
noise similarly to your method. So have
you have you compared your methods to
uh particular in cell codes with mispl?
Yes. Um so this this particular um uh
standard the one that we just showed
here is using a piewise linear function
in terms of how they do the
interpolation when they the shape
function is wise linear because they
don't really use a delta function to get
it done. But we have the other we want
to the goal here is after we get our 2D
working we now want to compare it with
future problems to be able to see how
maybe like well known well known codes
available like sim and what have you big
and what have to see how it performs but
this one is using pace line the standard
they use pw not just a delta function
they approated it by using delta pwise
Okay, thank you. Uh, next question is by
Andrea. Andrew, if you want to unmute
and ask directly.
Hi. Uh, so my question is like have you
looked at the error in other quantities
such as like the charge density or
number density and uh or the
distribution function itself?
So for distribution function I have not
but the other quantities we have looked
at it and comparably the only thing is
as the particle so if you go below below
20,000 the the
the error our error will start fail if
you go below 20,000 you realize earlier
then go back so
you're not sharing you're not sharing
Okay.
Yeah. So there are there are issues. So
when you go beyond this when you compare
the exact solution of our charge density
as compared to the one with standard P
our results now that's where the error
is not as good. So basically just with
my elementary understanding realize that
you can only reduce the particles to a
particular kind of limitation. There's a
limit you can reduce the the particles
up to beyond
that the method will not be working as
much as you want it to. Yes. In terms of
distribution function, we tried doing
it, but it's basically a bit technical
because it looks like we're converting
apples to oranges because we'll need to
make sure we have all our uh four
variables at a particular time to see
what happens at that particular time
with the standard B. It's uh it's
there's a bit of work that we have to do
the B. We didn't do the F by terms of
energy. Here we are looking at energy by
energy in terms
of in terms of char density compared to
our one it's it works well.
Okay. Um do you want to unmute again?
You always ask me after I type it all
up. Okay. Uh okay. So, um I was
wondering if your code is designed to or
happens to have only been used as
uh one in which all these moments that
you keep
uh evolve are the same number of moments
for all the particles independently of
where the particle happens to be in
velocity space.
I didn't get a question.
That was Can you repeat?
Oh, okay. You didn't hear or should I
use different language? What was the
problem? I I Oh, okay. Well, stop me if
if you don't hear me again. Okay. Uh the
same thing doesn't happen everywhere in
phase space in a physics simulation of
an interesting problem. For instance, if
you have land damping, there's a
particular phase velocity at which the
wave is born and lives and that happens
to be because it's an electron plasma
wave something like 3 or 4 V thermal.
Okay. So natural units at velocities of
three or four which is very far in the
tail of the Maxwellian distribution
function, right? Yes. Yes. Okay. So, do
you treat those particles any
differently than you treat the bulk
particles or ones with even higher
velocity in what what do you what is the
velocity space localized information
that you're using before using words
like smart particle? The first thing
particles know is where they are in
velocity space. Is your method smart
enough to know that? Yes.
How is it different? How does it use
different moments depending on where it
is in velocity space? I didn't see
anything on your slides about that or
maybe I missed it.
So in in the kind of how how the de
composition is done. So the reason why
you you don't see you
remember when I was in our first toy
problem. The reason
why here this where the moment
is right in when L is one or uh sorry
when L is greater than two you then have
have this and this is where we have our
standard the standard pin by points.
Okay. So when you are um dealing with
this side that's where you need to now
keep track properly of how our um
velocity and the velocity in terms of
the face space is what is moving. So in
this example we didn't we are not
tracking this at all here but in the the
next work that we are doing definitely
you need to handle the two tails
properly to make sure it's um aligned
properly with what and that's why
said earlier K means look good here but
we need maybe a better clustering
mechanism to deal with it when we are
now moving beyond the equals 0 and one
I think you're saying that you're more
focused on the Hamiltonian aspects and
space reduction and this sort of thing
allahinstein and uh And that has nothing
to do with the sampling part which is a
separate thing. Is that what you're
saying? Yes.
Okay. I would say that if you combine
the two then you can use words like
smart. Sure. Okay.
All right. Well, thank you to um I think
it's times up to wrap up
7. Yeah. So, let's thank our speaker for
the nice talk and wonderful Q&A session
and and thank you all also who you know
who participated this nice uh special
seminar we
hosted the best
well thank you thank you
again all All right.